that is a photography gallery is
designed on the disused site so we hit
upon the idea of using 19 containers as
a bleach to create a photography gallery
while at the same time is designed to
specific events when the brief was given
to us it was meant to be able to be
dismantled at the earlier stitch during
the design phase we had to design the
interfacing of the containers as well as
the electrical services running within
to be able to be pulled apart the site
itself was disused and two sides were
actually blank walls which doesn't have
any windows facing it so the opening to
the street was quite narrow the
breakthrough came when we realized that
deck should not just be a photography
calorie but it could be a activator of
the urban space so from then on the
whole design evolved and this is where
we are today another one what challenges
we faced was that this was the first
time we were working with containers our
process actually included some of us
having to go down to the shipyards to
actually select the containers you
wanted we actually sketched out details
especially how to put them together or
even preventing rain coming in it's
almost a paradox that living in
Singapore and with the way with a custom
to designing our projects this was
almost a change to push that local
design to a higher level the president
designer what it gives us a platform to
showcase good works having a chance to
win this award has really encouraged the
whole team our rights or emerging
designers is to understand that you
never really will design something good
if you don't really go out and
experience life what we start out in the
journey might not always be the way you
will end and I think embracing a change
make design exciting